FOLLOWING PRESIDENT BIDEN'S
CATASTROPHIC WITHDRAWAL IN
AFGHANISTAN, AMERICA MAY BE
FACING AN ELEVATED TERROR THREA
HERE AT HOME FROM GROUPS LIKE
AL-QAEDA.
REMEMBER AL-QAEDA?
25 DAYS WE WILL BE COMMEMORATIN
THE 25th ANNIVERSARY OF THE 9-
11 ATTACKS THAT TOOK SO MANY
AMERICAN LIVES.
NOW TOP PENTAGON OFFICIALS AND
OTHERS ARE WARNING THAT TERROR
WAS BACK --
BASED IN AFGHANISTAN COULD BUNC
NEW ATTACKS HERE ON THE US
OLYMPIC GIVEN THAT NIGHTMARE
SCENARIO, LAWMAKERS NOW SLAMMIN
PRESIDENT BIDEN AND ACCUSING HI
OF PUTTING AMERICAN LIVES AT
RISK.
>> THE BIGGEST THING, IT'S A
DISASTER FOR OUR
COUNTERTERRORISM.
AL-QAEDA 3.0 WILL COME ROARING
BACK.
AL-QAEDA AND TALIBAN ARE MARRIE
AT THE HIP.
WITH THIS TIME WHEN WE GO BACK
IN, THE TALENT BANNED ARE GOING
TO BE BETTER ARMED WITH TAXPAYE
FUNDED EQUIPMENT AND WE HAVE NO
ALLIES BECAUSE THEY HAVE ALL
BEEN HUNTED DOWN.
I WANT TO SEE RESIGNATIONS.
>> THAT WANT TO SEE RESIGNATION
ALSO BUT I HAVE A SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT TAKE ON IT.
REMEMBER WHAT HAPPENED THE LAST
TIME THE TALIBAN HOSTED AL-QAEDA
.
AL-QAEDA HAD US.
WE CAME BACK AND WIPED OUT THE
TALIBAN AND TOOK THEIR COUNTRY.
ANOTHER FOR US, IT COST THEM
THEIR COUNTRY FOR 20 YEARS.
FIVE WOULD BE THEY BE SO EAGER
THAT THE HAVE THEIR COUNTRY BAC
TO SPONSOR --
>> THEY ALREADY ARE.
>> THERE IS A SILVER LINING.
THEY HAVE TO KEEP IT.
BUT YOU START KEEPING A LAND YO
BECOME A TARGET.
CAN'T BE UNDERGROUND FOREVER SO
THAT HELP --
TALIBAN STARTS DOING SOME
HEINOUS, THE GOING TO BE PUBLIC
ABOUT IT.
WE HAVE TO CREATE A WAY, I CALL
THE PEST-CONTROL ANALOGY, TERRO
CONTROL BUT I AM HAPPY THAT GEN
MARK MILLEY MOVED UP AND --
BUT STILL NOT AS EQUAL AS A
TRUMP FOLDER.
>> THE WAR ON TERROR WAS
SUPPOSED TO SHIFT BY SUPREMACY.
THIS HAS GOT TO SHAPE DON LEMON
'S BY.
I YOU'VE GOT TO DEAL WITH THE
TALIBAN.
I HOPE IF THE TALIBAN CREATES A
GOVERNMENT, IT IS EASIER TO
ANNIHILATE THEM IF WE CHOOSE
BECAUSE THEY ARE NOW NOT HIDING.
>> AS LONG AS THEY DON'T BRING
WHITE SUPREMACIST.
>> IT COULD BE WHITE
SUPREMACISTS.
>> YOU MAY DISAGREE WITH THE
ANALYSIS.
I SUPPORT AL-QAEDA WHEN AL-QAED
IS SO HOT.
>> I DON'T DISAGREE THAT WOULD
MAKE LOGICAL SENSE.
THE PROBLEM IS AL-QAEDA HAS
ALREADY PLEDGED TO THERE.
THE TALIBAN HAS BEEN WORKING
WITH THEM AND HE WAS PURPOSELY
SAID THAT.
I THINK THE FACTS OF THE GROUND
IT'S NOT JUST AL-QAEDA WITH
EVERY OTHER SORT OF ISLAMIC
TERRORISM GROUP NOW.
EVEN IF THEY DON'T COME TO
AFGHANISTAN, THAT MIGHT BE WHER
THE TALIBAN GET SMART.
MAYBE THEY SAY DON'T, HERE.
>> THERE ARE LIKE 20 OF THEM, 2
DIFFERENT GROUPS.
>> I THINK THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING IN THE LAST 20 YEARS HAS
BEEN WE DIDN'T START THE WAR.
REMEMBER, THE WAR CAME TO US AN
THEN WE DECIDED TO GO ON THE
OFFENSE.
THAT HAS TO REMAIN.
REMIND EVERYBODY THAT YOU CAN
GET INTO THE SEPTEMBER 10
THINKING AND COMPLACENCY.
REMEMBER THE 3:00 A.M. PHONE
CALL IN 2016.
WE DIDN'T TALK TOO MUCH OF THAT
AND 2020.
WE PROBABLY SHOULD HAVE.
>> SO WHAT YOU THINK ABOUT
AL-QAEDA?
>> WELL, THE LEGITIMACY OF THE
SCRIPT THAT WAS BASICALLY
DEFUNCT COMING BACK.
>> WELCOME A BIG IMMEDIATE
THREAT BY THE AMERICANS THAT AR
STILL IN AFGHANISTAN.
IF ONE OF THOSE AMERICANS OR ON
OF OUR ALLIES DIES AT THE HANDS
OF THE TALIBAN, JOE THINKS
THINGS ARE BAD NOW, AFTER THAT
HAPPENS, IT'S GOING TO BE A YOU
RON HOSTAGE SITUATION.
ALSO THESE REFUGEES, SOME OF
THEM DESERVE TO HAVE AMNESTY AN
TO COME HERE.
DO I TRUST JOE BIDEN TO GET THEM
?
OF COURSE I DON'T.
IT DOES NOT LOOK LIKE GOOD
BIDDING IS GOING ON AT THE KABU
AIRPORT RIGHT NOW.
AND TO THINK THAT THE GUY THAT
LET THE BOSTON BOMBERS COME IN
HERE AFTER RUSHER SAID --
>> THEY WERE ALERTED BY MOSCOW
TO THIS ADMINISTRATION AND WE
DIDN'T DO ANYTHING BECAUSE THER
WAS THIS MISSPELLING.
THEY'LL PULL OF THE SHOOTER AND
HERE AFTER --
PLASTERED WITH JIHADIST
PROPAGANDA.
I DON'T TRUST JOE TO VET.
GREAT QUESTION AT THE BRIEFING
TO JAKE SULLIVAN, SHE HAD A
MASCULINE SHE SUCKED BUT ABOUT
THE NATO ALLIES.
WHAT ABOUT TAIWAN.
WHAT ABOUT SOUTH KOREA.
ARE WE GOING TO DEFEND THEM
AFTER BUT WE JUST WITNESSED AND
PROPAGANDA GIFT TO RUSSIA, CHINA
, NORTH KOREA, THEY'RE JUST
GOING TO TELL THE TARGET YOU
THINK THE AMERICANS ARE
CONFIDENT ENOUGH.
IT'S GOING TO HURT.
>> IS A BIG DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
TAIWAN AND AFGHANISTAN.
AFGHANISTAN IS IN THE MIDDLE OF
NOWHERE.
WHAT WAS YOUR FIRST FEELING WHE
YOU SAW THE CROWDS AT THE
AIRPORT YESTERDAY AND SUNDAY?
>> THAT IT WAS A HORRIBLE VISUA
BUT IT IS GOING TO STICK TO THI
PRESIDENCY.
THAT IS ONE OF THE THINGS,  YOU
CAN ALWAYS TELL WHEN SOMETHING
IS A GREAT WITH A DISCREET WITH
ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
BUT HAS THAT KIND OF A
REVERBERATION.
SO MANY PEOPLE THINK IN PICTURES
.
THAT IS WHAT THAT LATCH ONTO.
I THINK IN TERMS OF TERROR,  I
HOPE TO GOD THAT THERE'S NOT A
TERROR ATTACK HERE AND WE'VE
GIVEN UP SO MANY OF OUR CIVIL
LIBERTIES DURING THE PANDEMIC
THAT WE COULD HAVE A MASSIVE
COMPROMISE IF THERE IS A TERROR
ATTACK HERE.
IS YOUR POINT, I DON'T TRUST
ANYONE IN FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO
ANY TYPE OF VETTING BECAUSE THE
SHOWN THEIR FAILURE OVER AND
OVER AGAIN.
I THINK COPS WILL COME UP BETTE
FROM THIS BECAUSE THEY HAVE BEE
SO DEMONIZED DURING THE PANDEMI
AND UP WHEN YOU SEE NYPD
OFFICERS WITH THE
COUNTERTERRORISM BADGE, PEOPLE
GO, OKAY, SOMEONE IS HERE WHO'S
GOING TO PAY ATTENTION TO THE
STUFF AND THE GOING TO KEEP ME
SAFE.
>> JUST ONE LAST NOTE ABOUT THIS
.
MY TRANSLATOR FOR MANY YEARS IN
AFGHANISTAN IS HIDING OUT IN
KABUL HOPING TO GET ONE OF THOS
RIGHT THROUGH THE TALIBAN
ROADBLOCKS TO THE AIRPORT.
MANY INTERNATIONAL GROUPS ARE
WORKING TO GET